when it comes to the United Nations it's
really not surprising when many
countries are against Israel it's been
happening for decades it's not
particularly newsworthy and so it wasn't
surprising to me and to anybody who
knows anything about the United Nations
when the UN held a vote recently in
their General Assembly about Donald
Trump deciding to recognize Jerusalem as
the capital of Israel something I've
called a terrible idea and the General
Assembly rejected it they said now we
don't accept Donald Trump and the u.s.
recognising Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel for a number of reasons including
the fact that it is a disputed territory
and internationally it's not considered
the capital of Israel so what did Donald
Trump do he decided to threaten
withholding according to him billions of
dollars in American aid from the
countries that voted to reject his
recognition of Jerusalem and this all
started when ambassador to the UN nikki
Haley wrote to the hundred and eighty of
the hundred ninety three countries that
rejected Trump's recognition of
Jerusalem that she will be quote taking
names of who voted how and then Donald
Trump made the threat about withholding
aid this is more or less a total lack of
knowledge of the history and political
realities of this issue of the
israeli-palestinian conflict more
broadly it's even sort of a reflective
or indicative of a total lack of
understanding of the United Nations as
well this vote is not at all surprising
but it's also not controversial and
that's why this is so boneheaded
Jerusalem is a disputed territory it's
by and large not recognized as the
capital of Israel and recognizing it as
such
would go against a number of UN Security
Council resolutions on exactly this
issue the real exposition from this
stunt is how little Donald Trump knows
what's going on right I assume that most
of our audience agrees with me on this
issue so I want to talk for a second to
the people who think oh the recognition
of Jerusalem as the capital of Israel is
a really good thing and these threats by
Trump are great because
he's doing the right thing and he's not
taking no for an answer and Jerusalem
should be the capital of Israel and
Trump is calling it what it is well take
for a second the pragmatic and practical
approach Trump said he would solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict well
actually more hilariously he said Jared
Kushner would solve it which is totally
laughable how is this going to help
Donald Trump solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict it does the
opposite it exposes Trump as a clueless
and biased arbiter in the conflict and
therefore it hurts American credibility
in being a negotiator of a peace
agreement with little credibility that
we had left the United States is fully
exposed as a biased participant in
whatever hypothetical negotiations might
someday happen this is a guy in Trump
who's ideologically compromised on this
and these decisions are making it worse
day after day after day now as far as
the threats to cut aid go my guess is
that these threats are like a lot of
what Donald Trump says totally and
utterly empty threats but if they are
not and Donald Trump actually starts
cutting aid from countries because of
this vote the monumental damage that it
will do to our relationships with allies
will be absolutely stunning and I
actually don't know what's worse here
Trump thinking he knows how to solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict or the side
effects of the entire world realizing
that they need to do everything they can
to keep Trump away from this conflict
altogether as well as Jared Kushner and
David Freese yeah those are the
repercussions and I think this is just
entirely a play to his base right I mean
even the idea of moving the embassy to
Jerusalem I think his supporters would
be in support of that but not be able to
rationalize why exactly when and the
same thing happens when he threatens the
UN in pulling foreign aid from other
countries yeah even though it's like
less than 1% of the federal budget
different people would be supportive of
different elements of this for different
reasons right the evangelical followers
of Trump as we saw from a recent speech
from one of his cronies I don't even
remember who they believed that maybe
the recognition of Jerusalem as the
capital might bring about the second
coming of Jesus Christ n times rapture
apocalypse whatever everyone dies
everyone
but it's great because they end up in
heaven the trunk doesn't take BS from
the UN crowd which is a different crowd
in general than the evangelical crowd
they might like the threats to cut aid
based on the UN vote it is in a sense
red meat but it's like stupid red meat
or it's red meat from a diseased animal
that no one should be eating maybe is a
better analogy and pardon the analogy to
vegan Pat but I think it's a fitting
analogy here this is not good for
anybody and it's an absolute disaster
that we'll probably be dealing with in
more detail in 2018 today's program is
made possible in part by Blue Sky
binaries blockchain Academy blockchain
the technology on which Bitcoin and
crypto currencies can be based many
people not aware of both the power and
the risks that are carried by blockchain
technology I've only started to get into
this a little bit buying a little bit of
Bitcoin here and their dollar cost
averaging but a lot of people myself
included believe that blockchain
technology is just too complicated to
understand but the truth is it doesn't
have to be that way the blue sky binary
blockchain Academy from leading
financial education firm blue sky binary
explains how blockchain works and it can
work in addition to existing knowledge
that you have about blockchain it's for
both beginners and active cryptocurrency
users alike with the course students are
taken through a series of topics which
ultimately will deliver a very solid
understanding of how blockchain works
and helps students realize the potential
future uses of blockchain technology
we've talked about this in the
pharmaceutical world we've talked about
this in the IT security world many many
possibilities for blockchain and the
course includes video on-demand online
tests access to a community of traders
and blockchain enthusiasts and at blue
sky binary.com / David you can register
to get a free three-day trial which
includes access to the first module of
the course for you to evaluate the
overall quality and decide if you want
to stick with it get a free three-day
trial at blue sky binary.com / David